throughout the story and the different
adventures of the straw hat crew
there is a symbol that appears in
seemingly unrelated places
over and over again it's a big sphere
with eight satellites around it
the symbol appears on skypia in the
crest of the shandians
in the flag of alabasta and even in wano
where it's part of the kazuki crest now
what sort of meaning could this symbol
possibly have
to connect these three honestly quite
different places
could it actually be that without us
realizing it
oda has actually already subtly revealed
the symbol of the ancient kingdom
the people probably most literate in the
history of the world
next to maybe the gorosei and imu were
the scholars on the island of o'hara
inside their library we can see an
enormous globe
that you're probably familiar with that
seems to show the one-piece world
surrounded by multiple spheres
now similarly to our scientific history
it's of course entirely possible
that the scholars of ahara simply
believe the earth to be the center of
the solar system
and these objects are the planets
circling the earth
however i personally think it's not at
all far-fetched to assume
that they were actually way more
sophisticated than that
what this would mean is that these orbs
would in fact have to be multiple moons
circling the planet
now if that were to be the case how is
it that we only ever get to see
one single moon in the sky at night
throughout the entire story
the one moon that we know from another's
cover story that he himself calls verth
now we know for a fact that this moon
did indeed harbor life at some point in
the past
and that the burqas the winged people of
skypea originally came from there as
they fled to earth for a lack of
resources
so what about these other moons from the
astronomical model on o'hara
well what if in the past instead of one
there were actually
eight moons each with its own
intelligent life form
culture and technology due to some
unknown event
these moons were abandoned and or
destroyed at some point in the past
and its different people fled to earth
to start a new life there
where do i get the number 8 from you ask
well we'll get to that in a second
now as it so happens we actually do know
a variety of humanoid races
inhabiting the one piece world that all
have their own culture
history and traditions the giants the
fishmen the tontata
the long limb tribes the minks the sky
people
humans as well as a number of other
potential races
such as the 3i tribe and possibly even a
demon or devil race
each of these groups could have
originally inhabited their very own
world on each of the moons
and this concept is actually nothing new
if you watched my video on shanks you
will know that oda draws a lot of
inspiration from nordic mythology
and one of the most important elements
in nordic mythology
is ikdrazil the world tree that harbors
a total
of nine connected worlds the world in
the center is called midgard
the realm of men and around it eight
worlds inhabited by other races
these races also include dwarves and
giants that as a matter of fact we
already know to live in the one piece
world as well
and especially the giants as well as
their island elbaf
have clearly been inspired by nordic
mythology
this also includes a gigantus tree that
is being hinted at in this scene here
could this be a reference to iggdrazil
and the nine worlds
i think it's quite likely and notably
one of these worlds
also is said to harbor a race of demons
now being forced to leave their own
worlds behind each of these races will
have come down to earth
the world of humans and the last
inhabitable place left
here the different people lived in
constant conflict and war with each
other
born from the never-ending power
struggles and deep-rooted prejudice
one day however a charismatic and
powerful leader enters the stage
and starts gathering members of all the
different races under his flag
this diverse and unprecedented group
starts to grow an influence in
popularity
due to its shared wisdom friendship and
equality
at some point it grows so large and
influential
that it establishes a kingdom that grows
into a place of peace and prosperity
and the leader of this kingdom is a man
known by the name of
joyboy joyboy's ultimate goal is to
unite all the different races and bring
the endless warring and violence amongst
them to a close
and segregation and racism and create a
united world of freedom and justice
so arguably what the story of one piece
will in the end be all about
we do know that joyboy was already
starting to fulfill this plan
as he promised the fishman to bring them
up to the surface and give them
equal rights to the humans however with
the growing influence of the ancient
kingdom
and its ideals of equality and freedom
the kingdom of the humans started to
feel threatened and plan to overthrow
joy boy
20 of them banded together to declare
war on the ancient kingdom
but initially failed due to its immense
shared wisdom
power and technology however when the
war threatened to be lost
they were unexpectedly offered help by
the king of the demon clan
which was despised and feared by all the
other races
he offered the kings to share the powers
of his people with them in order to turn
the tides against the ancient kingdom
and make them the gods and new rulers of
the entire world
all of this however under one condition
that he would become the one true king
ruling from the shadows blinded by the
power of this offer
19 of the 20 kings took the deal and so
the demon king bestowed upon them
the power of the devil fruits one of
them however
the king of alabasta was wary of the
devil and his power
and secretly decided to inform joyboy
about the coming threats
upon hearing about the new fantastic
powers of their enemies and their
inevitable defeat
joyboy decided to do everything in his
power to ensure that his vision would be
made reality someday
the kozuki clan that were part of his
kingdom
created the ponoglyphs with instructions
and information about the true history
of the world
meanwhile using its advanced technology
the ancient kingdom created three
powerful weapons to oppose the power of
devil fruits
the powers of poseidon to command
powerful sea monsters inherited by the
fishmen
the power of pluton a mighty battleship
capable of destroying entire islands
as well as uranus a weapon of unknown
power
that might have enabled space travel and
finally
some secret was hidden on an island that
would later become known as
love tale just as joy boy had feared the
tides of the war
quickly changed with the sudden
appearance of the devil fruit powers
with their help the kings artificially
changed the geography of the entire
planet
to ensure their rule and position of
power for centuries to come
and so the ancient kingdom fell and the
world had to wait for the return of a
new joy boy
that would finally fulfill his dream and
unite the world